closer than it appears one of the
largest discovery of liquid natural gas
in the last two
decadesanji the fossil fuel is both a
blessing and a curse it spells the end
of a lifetime catching fish in the area
but the promise what the government says
will be a prosperous future
I want us to profit from the gas because
as soon as we start extracting I expect
that electricity prices fuel even food
prices will drop and become affordable
for us he is not alone Europeans no
longer wanting to rely on Russian gas
are looking at Africa to meet their
energy needs Germany and Poland have
signed deals with Senegal's government
Europeans will have access to Senegal's
resources before its own citizens and so
this has left many Senegalese wondering
how much will they benefit from their
own country's resource because so far
for many young men opportunity means
boarding one of these fishing vessels to
travel to Europe illegally the
government hopes that the gas project
will stop this and bring jobs here at
home at the country's new oil and gas
Institute engineers and doctorates are
given certified training for industry
jobs as the resources belong to the
Senegalese people for the Institute
director The Fallout of the Russia
Ukraine conflict on Europe's energy
problems may offer an opportunity for
African countries to change the power
dynamics we want Senegalese in the
leadership position we want to be able
to have whenever it comes in decision
making this is Project four Senegal for
the development of the country and it's
important that we have our
Senegalese National sitting at the table
representing the government
the consequences of a conflict in Europe
away from this continent is affecting
enjai's future the Senegalese Coast
Guard appears in the distance not to
protect fishermen like him but the
precious new resource destined for
Europe
with the state offering him training in
welding and electricity the end of life
on the ocean appears to be on the
horizon
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Senegal San
Luis